[Music]
joining me today is an author the
political editor of townhall.com and a
fox news contributor guy Benson welcome
to the Reuben report thanks for having
me this is great I am looking forward to
talking to you but we've got to say
first Fox News contributor a certain
amount of people are gonna hate you
already right out of the gate what do
you do with that kind of information
well I think it's interesting how some
people use labels as a substitute for
argument so I'll make a point on Twitter
for example and someone on the Left will
check my bio and just respond
oh well Fox News contributor as if that
means anything is if that's a response
to anything that I've actually argued
and I'll say good point you know like
where are you going with that and
usually they sort of scuttle off
somewhere but I'm very happy to work
there I've been proud to work there for
four years it's a great platform and one
thing that sometimes people ask me about
it is you know there's elements that are
very Pro Trump and others that aren't
and are you ever told or encouraged to
think something or say something on the
air and the answer hand to heart is no
never
which I value greatly and I think if
that were different I would probably not
want to stick around and that's never
happened
full editorial independence which is I
think crucial for a thriving Network and
I've been afforded that yeah and I will
back you on that much I haven't done as
much Fox's stuff as you have but I had
been on O'Reilly I've done Tucker I've
done Gutfeld they let you go on and say
whatever you want the chips will fall
where they may but in terms of editing
you know a lot of this stuff is live and
it kind of is what it is but people just
have a feeling that somehow there's
something evil or that there's an
editorial line yeah we somehow get a
memo at the beginning of every day
here's what we think about this today I
mean it's it's ludicrous and just look
at the people I think a lot of the
critics of Fox don't watch Fox they see
short clips of it on the daily show or
on Samantha B or whatever highlighting a
particularly preposterous moment and
they say well it must be that 24/7
that's not how it is and sometimes when
people are really skeptical or cynical
about the network I'll encourage them to
watch Brett Bay or show special report
and I say give that a shot for a week
watch 2 or 3 episodes and then come back
to me and let me know if you have the
exact same perception of Fox and do they
ever do it but they have everywhere he's
pretty Center that guy sometimes they do
and they're like all right this is this
is a legit show I'm like ok this is
progress that's that's a small amount of
breaking for watch air yeah all right so
we're going to talk a lot about your
book and a discussion we met briefly
about 2 years ago in the after party at
Real Time with Bill Maher and the hard
cover had come out the the soft cover
which we have right here just came out
so before we get into the book though
you're gay and a court are we breaking
this news on on the Rubin report it says
it right there doesn't well the card
can't be wrong yeah I mean this is a
blue card with typing that's it yeah on
television or whatever wherever we're
sending this out to something yes you're
gay and you're a Republican yeah well I
just dropped my cards because of that
how could this possibly be I would
consider myself more of a conservative
than a Republican okay I tend to vote
Republican because the Democratic Party
to me is a completely inhospitable place
for me based on my beliefs in my
worldview but the party the Republican
Party frustrates me deeply
on a frequent basis so I feel like I'm
less attached to the are label than I am
to the conservative one but so let's do
that part first actually then what so
tell me what does being a conservative
mean to you then we'll get to this sure
we'll get to the gay stuff Tim how great
to me it just means that I believe
fundamentally that the government
especially the federal government isn't
particularly good at doing very many
things at all and they do too many
things and they do them badly a great
expense to all of us and I think they
should do fewer things do them better
and preferably the things that they are
required to do under the Constitution
and not a constantly expanding array of
tasks that they accumulate and it costs
a lot of us a lot of money so a small
government conservative is sort of
where I come from I foreign-policy I'm
somewhere in the middle of the party or
the conservative movement I'm not a
hardcore hawk but I'm not a
non-interventionist either our non
interventionist and then on social
issues it's just a complete mixed bag
it's hard to pin me down bro gay
marriage pro-life sort of all over the
map and given that panoply of issues and
I look at where the parties stand you
know or where the movements are in this
country I do agree with the left on some
things but it's just outweighed by the
right on most issues I lean to the right
and therefore I tend to vote Republican
yeah so by conventional thinking though
people would say wait a minute you can't
be a gay conservative how could you have
fought for gay marriage for example from
a conservative perspective how do you
answer something like that I just think
it's a completely false premise the idea
that someone has to prioritize their
politics based on their identity I think
is a toxic corrosive lefty construct
that I just completely reject right if I
wanted to be a gay person who's against
gay marriage I have every right to think
that way I happen to support gay
marriage I hope to get married but and
there are some of those that exist by
them yeah they're they're out there for
sure and if that's you know let's have
that discussion I'm not gonna call you
self-hating because you don't support
every single one of the agenda items of
a political party or a political
movement or the LGBT community or
whatever it might be to me I look at my
priorities in terms of the elements on
policy that animate me that I think
about the most that I am concerned about
the most and if I sort of weigh them it
tilts in the rightward direction which
is why I am a conservative that doesn't
mean that I think the Republican Party
represents me perfectly or even
particularly well on gay rights issues I
also think it's an odd it's a it's an
odd vantage point or an odd demand that
some people on the Left try to make that
if you are a sir
way if you're in a certain column or a
category of people you have to then vote
for a certain party or what have you
would you prefer that there is nobody on
the other side of the aisle making
arguments to perhaps modernize the
platform for example the Republican
Party or to introduce the idea that
there are gay people that are not all
that scary I mean in this process of
being on the book tour for two years and
speaking to a lot of conservative
audiences I have been really struck by
just the kindness and the sweetness that
I've encountered from a lot of
traditional conservatives who are not
necessarily even on board for gay
marriage but are sort of like oh maybe
maybe we're you know we're sort of
rethinking some of this a little bit one
story that comes to mind in particular
that I enjoy telling was I was at an
event in Denver
a year and a half ago maybe and we were
doing a book signing this was the
hardcover back then and fortunately
there is a long line so people were
coming up and they're wanting photos and
that sort of thing and there is this
woman who was probably in her 60s and
she approached me and she got the book
sign and she was I could tell she wanted
to say something else and she didn't
know if to say it or how to say it and
finally she just sort of blurted it out
whispered a little she goes I have a
nephew who's the way you are and it was
it was just this very cute way of sort
of trying to just say you know and I
love him yeah that was her way of trying
to communicate about it and just sort of
Pat me on the shoulder and say you're
welcome you're welcome here and you know
we've got your back and there's been
some of that and frankly my favorite
response that I've gotten from
conservatives since I came out in the
book actually years ago so the timing
was all I mean you did this sort of in
lockstep well and and I can explain that
in a second but I was just gonna say my
favorite response has been ambivalence
people just being like noted moving on
right that's the best response to me
because the reason that I didn't come
out publicly soon
because I felt like it was no one's
business mm-hmm this is my personal life
anyone who knew me closely my family my
friends my colleagues they all knew yeah
I just wasn't publicly gay because I
didn't want to pigeonhole myself right
out of the gate in my career as the gay
whatever I wanted people to start to
read my work see me on TV and get a
sense of you know the content of what I
put out rather than viewing me through
an identity lens immediately but because
we delve into some of these issues gay
rights and religious liberty and so on
in an entire chapter of the book
entitled bake me a cake bigots I felt
like at that point if I'm going to write
10,000 words on an issue I should
probably disclose just journalistically
that I'm gay so I did it in a footnote
in the book and I felt it was the right
time for the right reason yeah so when
you go on the tour and and you're
meeting now these conservatives and
you're doing book signings and things
like that and most of them don't care do
you think that's the best way to
actually change people's minds you know
that all you did do you put in a
footnote okay now here I am let's go
ahead did you get any blowback a little
bit but it was like pretty legit people
I mean maybe from some haters on Twitter
but was there any because I get this all
the time because people because I think
we're going to agree on the on the cake
I'm pretty sure we don't know the gay
cake thing and I'll say well people you
know people say to me well see you're
tolerating the these Republicans who
hated you all these years I'm like well
they've changed a lot actually there's
been a huge sea change I also don't
accept that someone having a political
disagreement or not wanting to
participate in a gay wedding it quoits
to hating me um so I try to be more
generous in spirit on that sort of thing
but you're also allowed to hate people
I mean you are it doesn't that's kind of
uncomfortable we don't like it I don't
encourage they don't encourage it I
would rather not haven't but you are
even for bad reasons you're allowed to
date you're not allowed to hurt people
right you know physically but you are
allowed to have your own bigoted views
it's just how it is yeah but I think I'd
like to change those views but and
that's part of I think what you do right
that's just doing the show and reaching
out to new especially younger audiences
they're sort of like Oh
open people's minds in a society where
we seem to be trending in the other
direction the wrong direction but your
question reminds me of another stop on
the tour this one was in New Mexico I
believe and my co-authors Mary Katharine
ham
she's like a very very dear friend we've
been almost like siblings at this point
and she's at CNN now so we were in in
Albuquerque and during the Q&A we had
done our normal spiel about the book and
someone asked her it had just been
remember the day without women yep where
there's a strike doesn't show the impact
of women in society so a woman asked her
during the session how did you spend
your day without women and then I think
she thought like oh I should maybe just
ask guy anyway because I don't want to
only ask a question of Mary Katherine so
Mary Katherine gave this great answer
about the day without women and she was
very charming and very funny
and then she tossed it to me she's like
well what did you do with your day
without women I'm like that's sort of
everyday for me and I in my mind I was
like is this a joke that I should make
like this is just a straight-up
self-deprecating gay joke in front of a
an older conservative audience got a
huge laugh sort of punctured any
awkwardness about that and it was like
done yeah most people don't care which
is definitely progress and that's also
why you know just to have you here and
have this conversation people don't get
this kind of conversation too often
between two gay people that come from
things from a slightly different
political perspective right but I know
when I've had Milo here who you know
comes from a completely other political
I got sittin in this chair he's been in
that very it wasn't in this room but
you've been in that very chair okay
which will now taint you I'm sure in
some way that you'll never be able to
you know it's because I leave that one
but but point being that people that
when we've talked even though we come
from things from a different perspective
also that it's refreshing for people to
hear gay people talk about issues that
aren't just about fashion or whatever
the things that Bravo is telling you
yeah all gay people should care about I
mean that's so this is actually a story
that I've never told but when I in the
process
like every gay person has gone through
the process of coming out and if like
the first step is coming out to yourself
right and then you sort of for me I
expanded the circle of trust so to speak
and one of the conversations that I was
most dreading was with a very close
group of guy friends from college I went
to Northwestern and we were all at a
bachelor party weekend in Montreal for
one you know one of our buddies was
getting married and I just sort of felt
this was the time we were all together
yeah so I told them and they sort of
were shocked and they interrogated me
for an hour in the hotel like what do
you mean and I could sort of get the
sense from the line of questioning a
little bit they were like so the person
that we've gotten to know like is that
all real or all fake or what's going on
I'm like no no like I'm the conservative
Christian sports fan that you know yeah
I just happen to like dudes like that's
the only thing that's different because
there is this stereotype of what we are
supposed to like or dislike or and as I
have sort of grown into being gay you
start to meet more gay people and you're
sort of like oh these stereotypes are
beyond yeah they're silly some of them I
mean some of them are fair but a lot of
them are silly and I think now that it's
more we're in a more tolerant and open
society gay gay people LGBT Q people
come in all shapes and sizes and I'm
hoping that's becoming not just more
mainstream for average America but also
within the gay club there's a little bit
more openness to some diversity at least
that's my aspiration here interesting
because my next question was sort of
going to be the reverse of that which is
that right now I see the gay community I
see two things happening and they're
happening at the exact same time sort of
in parallel with each other one I see a
community that used to be really
irreverent and fun and over the top and
drag queens and any politically
incorrect joke and all that I see
starting to crumble because of some of
the stuff that you talk about in this
book about the political correctness now
steeping and so the people who used to
be the outsiders are now sort of the
insiders and they're becoming
politically correct but then I also at
the same time I see because of that that
I see a certain amount of gay people are
starting to shift away from leftism
because they're going wait a minute this
isn't fun anymore or something like
they've taken away something very
special that the gay community had do
you see that yeah although I think
probably some of it is just a backlash
to political correctness and that's by
no means exclusive to the gay community
right I think part of the reason we have
the president that we have is because
people got so tired of this stifling
weaponized political correctness from
the left that eventually a lot of people
on the right said we've had enough if
they're gonna bully us culturally
endlessly we're gonna go hire our own
bully and it is his orange and we're
gonna hire and that's that's who we have
I think a lot of this is a cultural
backlash and that of course extends to
you know a certain number of gay people
as well and there's also just lots of
good reasons to be a conservative if
you're a taxpayer I don't care what your
sexual orientation is if you think the
government is taking too much of the
money that you earn if you think the
military should be strong and defeat our
enemies if you believe like I do in the
pro-life cause there's lots of different
reasons why someone can end up within
the conservative movement I do think
that for people who are LGBT the
Republican Party's platform and a lot of
their rhetoric especially in the past
has been a barrier to entry which I
completely understand
I think the rhetoric and the toleration
is getting better it's by no means
perfect but it's getting better and I
think it's also a generational shift in
a lot of ways yeah I mean interestingly
Trump is the first president that ever
came in on a first term basically being
for Pro you know Pro gay marriage right
I mean or just a llama the first doesn't
wait he just doesn't care I mean Peter
Thiel spoke at the at the convention
Trump the week before the election was
on stage with a rainbow flag again I
have no idea what he thinks about Gabler
I just don't think he thinks it's an
issue and I think that that has
sort of just trickle down to people
where they're just like big damn what
yeah I mean he's done some things as
president that I know have really
inflamed the gay community but overall I
think it is and I'm as you know I'm not
a huge fan yet the president all the
time I try to be fair to him and one of
the things that I think is you have to
say is indisputably he's the most Pro
LGBT Republican president ever it's not
even close the fact that he had a gay
supporter on stage at the RNC talking
about being gay and being proud of being
gay and getting a standing ovation like
that's unheard of even we're winding the
clock for five ten years for sure so you
know he's asked about the gay marriage
he's like I'm fine with it and if you
look at public polling there's been
heavy movement on same-sex marriage in
terms of public opinion particularly
among self-identified Republicans and I
do think that probably Trump has helped
give some people sort of a mental
permission slit to be like oh like well
we like Trump and he doesn't seem to
care about this maybe we've got bigger
fish to fry maybe maybe I'm okay with
this now so do you think the anti-gay
stuff for the Republicans you know we
can sort of parse down where it
eventually came from and did Karl Rove
use it as a wedge issue with george w
bush or any of sf' but that there was an
odd alliance between the christian
conservatives that we're gonna be
socially conservative versus the small
government republicans and i said i
sense you're sort of both of those but
that that alliance didn't fully make
sense because republicans should have i
think taken them they could have taken a
moral stance on how government should
operate and said we we shouldn't be
involved in this and how two people want
to you know go about a private
relationship it's part they got a leg
they just got crushed into this thing
that here we are and i think the label
of socially conservative is a tricky one
especially for our generation and
younger people because if you look at a
lot of the public polling data and we
talk about this an end of discussion
throughout much of the modern era of
american punditry people talk about
social issues they're really talking
about - they're talking
about abortion and gay rights mm-hmm and
there's been this lazy assumption that
they're a package deal and people who
you can you can predict what someone
will believe about one issue based on
what they believe about the other yes
let me pause it there for a second
because I'm Pro gay marriage obviously
not only am i Pro gay marriage I married
a dude that's that's very proud that's
very Pro really on the record very very
pro but I but I am pro-choice but
grudgingly as I say every time and
you're Pro gay marriage not married so
we'll see if you really put it into
action but but you're pro-life but
that's the point so it doesn't always
work and it and if you look at the
polling data for younger people we have
moved heavily to the left or the
libertarian direction on gay rights but
are really the most pro-life generation
aside from senior citizens we are more
pro-life than Xers we are more pro-life
than boomers and so these are not a
package deal they're not linked together
and I think I've thought a lot about
this and I think some of it comes down
to the argument about fairness and
people's rights I think the right or the
anti gay marriage right really got its
clock cleaned when it came to explain to
people why gay marriage is really a
problem
who is that harming go and the arguments
are weak and I used to I used to believe
except sort of a lockstep conservative I
checked all the boxes and then you start
you know in college I started to think
critically about stuff I'm like okay
well here I am making these arguments
than they suck
like I know they suck I'm gonna keep
making them and it sort of like all
right I can't I have to abandon them
yeah
there isn't a concrete victim to gay
marriage that is persuasive to the
American people whereas on abortion I
think you can make an ethical scientific
moral case that there is clearly of a
wronged victim party in an abortion that
people are willing to listen to that and
at least think about it whereas with gay
marriage like well my brother's gay my
friend is gay my you know cousins a
lesbian what are you talking about yeah
um I think that's part it's it's the
paradigm of human rights
that I think makes these issues diverge
for a lot of young people yeah so my
audience knows that as we air this I am
off the grid completely so this is an
airing this is airing a couple weeks
after I've been gone so I'm trying not
to do too much topical stuff okay but as
we're taping this right now we're in the
middle of this thing with the Trump's
ban on trans people in the military I
think because we're both gay that people
probably want to get some answers out of
us and I always think it's kind of funny
you know when they put these letters
together LGBT I have no more inherent
knowledge of what it's like to be a
trans person than a straight person but
it does by default so first you agree
with that premise that you as a gay
person don't have any sort of innate
knowledge of yeah trans issues just on
its face yes although the one thing I
would push back on is there's probably a
little bit more empathy because I think
empathy yeah I think there's a lot of
people in America who really have
trouble wrapping their mind around
same-sex attraction generally it's just
not something that they've ever
experienced or like that's just I don't
understand how someone could be like
that I think that's also true for even
more people when it comes to trans folks
mhm and so that's where the empathy I
think for me exists even though I am by
no stretch an expert I'm not even sure
if I'm getting the pronouns right there
are so many rules yeah like and we get
we have to get into it or we have a
little subsection called transgressions
where we go through how speaking
incorrectly with the wrong terms or
problematically got people like you know
Katie Couric in trouble and then Dan
Savage in trouble and then to top it all
off RuPaul got in trouble I'm like we
are through the freakin looking-glass if
RuPaul is now transphobic or whatever
you know the the epithet is and I and I
don't think sometimes the trans
community or the LGBTQ community does
itself a great service by getting
reflexively offended by people using
words or asking question
just trying to figure things out and
learn yeah well that's sort of hysteria
and that sort of then lack of sense of
humor too is also goes to what I was
saying before about why I see gay people
sort of shifting to the center or even
to the right now because they they've
just kind of had it with that and it
reminds me that when we met two years
ago very briefly as I said it was a Bill
Maher and even since then by using a
word he got in trouble by the left even
though no one in their right mind thinks
that Bill Maher is a racist yeah so
where did the the genesis for this book
come from it came from it's so funny
because we've almost exclusively talked
spoken here about gay rights and it's
only one chapter in the book well that's
funny because I wanted to get it out of
the way and everything except you've now
asked a question the answer is the
Brendan Eich Mozilla episode of 2014
yeah connect fresh people on that yes so
this was the gentlemen out here in
California who helped co-found Mozilla
the Internet company and he was elevated
in 2014 to CEO of that company and then
it was revealed that he had donated like
$1,000 of his private money to
Proposition 8 which here in this state
was the one man one woman amendment 2008
passed by the way in this you know back
woods right wing place California and
this was this was a thought crime that
could not be tolerated and eventually to
make the long story short he was hounded
out of the company that he founded for
holding a mainstream political position
mm-hmm that Mary Katherine and I
happened to disagree with him on but we
were very troubled by how that all went
down and that was actually the catalyst
to get off of our asses and write this
thing because we're like can you be like
this is this is scary we disagree with
him but what happened to him doesn't
really feel like America to us and they
were like you know someone really ought
to write a book about this we're like oh
crap it's us that's a lot of work as you
know yeah but it was worth it and now
the book just came out in paperback this
month and the reason that we finally
decided all right we need to update this
thing so and the discussion came out in
June of 2015 one week before Donald
Trump announced that he was running for
president so his name did not appear in
the book once and so the new chapter
that we've added to the paperback
edition begins with the line Donald
Trump is president and Berkeley is
burning
perhaps we should revisit our subject
and what finally put us over the top was
Mary Katherine got an email from the LA
Times actually weeks and weeks ago at
this point saying you know with
everything happening in Berkeley and
Middlebury we'd love for you to write an
op-ed about your new book and then ten
minutes later she got a response email
again saying it has come to our
attention this is not a new but it was
as red-hot unfortunately hotter than
ever in terms of the topic which might
be good for book sales but it's bad bad
news for the country do you see any hope
for the counter movement to the end of
discussion that's happening in about
yeah I know yeah for a number of reasons
you know the we anticipated in the book
a backlash we had no idea that it would
come so quickly in the form of really
Donald Trump loses this giant middle
finger to this entire culture and some
people are like oh is that really what
happened it's not by any stretch the
entirety of it but if you don't believe
that political correctness and the
backlash against that was not a huge
part of the appeal of Donald Trump I
think you're asleep
I think it's indisputable in my view so
yeah I think that the when it comes to
this backlash and some of the hopeful
signs one is there have been increasing
efforts that pushback from the Academy
from within a dozens of professors at
Middlebury wrote and signed this amazing
letter about free expression after that
whole incident went down Jonathan height
from NYU has started this heterodox
heterodox University or Academy Academy
which i think is terrific and and people
are signing up because I think there are
people on the left looking over their
shoulders saying I thought I was a
liberal in good standing but you know
who knows who the jackals are gonna come
after next this is getting out of hand
so that's that's where we really derive
some hope where we're telling folks and
we speak on campuses and we really wrote
the book not to be a right-wing pound
the table book we're trying to persuade
people not to necessarily agree with us
on every issue but to join us on this
this fundamental question of are we
going to be a society that can actually
talk about things or not and if we can't
talk about things anymore
we're not gonna solve any of our
problems so in a sort of selfish way but
I guess also in a societal way every
time this eats another liberal or lefty
or progressive you must love it right I
mean like like the Evergreen State thing
with Brett Weinstein oh my god you must
have loved it cuz here's this guy is at
the furthest left college now he's the
furthest left professor deeply
progressive as he said to Tucker Carlson
and they ate him so you must be gone we
uh I told you you should buy the book
the the one that I get a kick out of
still because it's a few all a few years
old now this example but one of the
things that we argue in end of
discussion is that like the left is
forgetting how to argue even amongst
themselves right it's not just all this
demagogic fire at the right that's been
true for a while though it's getting
worse this is their form of argument now
this is their you know identity politics
and the imputing of motives and outrage
has supplanted rational argument and so
there was this episode towards the end
of the obama presidency where there was
a dust-up on the left over tea TPP so we
were talking about trade policies yeah
okay we're not talking about trans bans
or anything trade policy and Elizabeth
Warren the word trans was in it though
that is that is true trans-pacific that
is good so it may have confused a couple
people but good poll that being said
point taken
the President Obama was on the other
side of this issue from Elizabeth Warren
the senator who we also really go after
in the book and her sort of delicious
way but I digress
at one point Obama was asked about
Warren's criticism of TPP and he
responded by saying well Liz
blah blah blah and a bunch of people on
the left were like whoa did you just
refer to a sitting senator by her first
name that is really mansplaining and
patriarchal and really problematic and
including some members of the Senate
were attacking Obama for using her first
name and so we're like sitting back with
a giant thing of popcorn and we're like
oh excuse me but are you criticizing our
first black president because that seems
kinda racist based on your whole thing
and it got into this sexist versus
racist thing I'm like you guys this is
it this is getting bananas yeah and so I
don't know sometimes we try to give
those types of examples to say to
liberals like it's not we're not the
only victims of this and I also want to
make one other point the left isn't the
only perpetrators and so that's exactly
where I want there you go segue after
question great well no I'll let you do
it but what I wanted to know is because
that's what people say to me all the
time that I'm now because I've so
exposed this thing and I've so focused
on this intersectional monster that will
eat everyone and it will Pitt actually
black people against gay people and at
the oppression Olympics and we've all
you know victimhood is virtue in this
whole thing that somehow I've let the
right off the hook here so hook that
right for me we do it yeah so we if we
do and one of our goals was to be
intellectually honest and in fact in the
process of writing the book before this
was initially 2015 before we submitted
our final manuscript a very good buddy
of mine actually my ex's brother he is
one of the most well read sharpest guys
I know and he's he's an attorney he's
done very well his credentials are
impeccable academically and I asked him
I said look we're gonna be submitting
this manuscript we want to be
intellectually honest I know you're not
going to agree with me on policy issues
a B or C would you do us the favor and
the honor of reading the manuscript and
giving us feedback not about where we're
wrong but where we are not fair to
people on your side where we have
intellectual blind spots that would
potentially
turned someone off from being persuaded
by us so he read the whole thing and he
came back and he said this is actually
quite well-written
because like thanks they said it's funny
and I'm persuaded but here are six
examples of things where I think that
you would lose some credibility and we
went through all them and said this is
legit and we and we changed the
manuscript beforehand because we really
wanted to be fair and honest and that
includes being critical of our side and
even ourselves we give an example in
here where we have contributed
personally to this problem as well yeah
so where where have you contributed to
it so I remember and part of this is
just sort of the imputing of motives and
just the over-the-top outrage I was on
the air in Chicago I had a radio show my
first sort of gig out of college I had a
weekend show in Chicago and I was on the
air on a Sunday night in March of 2010
when Obamacare finally passed into law
and I had spent month after month
fighting this thing and for good reason
I was worried we would never be able to
uproot it and it seems that that was a
well-founded fear and I had really
poured my heart and soul and
intellectual all into this fight and
then I was watching it go down live on
the screen while I'm live on the air and
I remember the phone lines on my radio
show were absolutely jam-packed ten
lines from 15 minutes before the show
started until well after the show ended
people were so emotional and so was I
and I went on a rant during the show
about and I called out every single
Democratic Congress person from Illinois
and the surrounding states who had voted
for it and was doing a roll call of who
they had who we had to beat in the next
election by the way we bought him up
beat almost all of them but I took it a
step further and I was talking about
punishing their families and not giving
their kids jobs and not writing letters
of recommendation for their children and
it was it was too much and it was it was
unhinged outrage and that was you know
part of this outrage environment that
gets the better that gets the best of
our rational discourse discussion
sometimes so that was sort of an example
that I gave about myself and then we
also do this like during the Iraq war
there was this unfair conflation of
being against the war and being against
the troops
that's a dishonest way of arguing
criticizing Israeli policy is sometimes
immediately called anti-semitic there is
crossover believe me but I think making
that argument right out of the gate is
unfair
and then there is this impulse I think
on the right also to say black lives
matter is an anti-police or Prokop death
organization there's a lot of
demagoguery about that which i think is
grossly mischaracterizing how many
people who are associated with that
movement feel and what they believe and
what their genuine grievances might be
and why and so both sides argue this way
the reason that we go harder after the
left is because they control the
taste-making institutions in this
country they control academia they
control most of the media and they
control Hollywood and entertainment and
when you have that heft on your side and
you can sort of impose the culture much
more easily they they are the bigger
part of the problem I have no doubt
though if the roles were reversed yeah
human nature and bad authoritarian
impulses are not relegated to one side
we would be doing the same thing I think
I completely agree and it's why you know
people every now and again I'll say
something on Twitter and someone will
find something that I said five years
ago that was I said the other way and
it's and they'll be like gotcha yeah I'm
like no no actually circumstances change
the power or change I evolved which i
think is a little something of how
humans are supposed to operate yes and
that power corrupts and that suddenly
you lose your your moral compass when
you're suddenly magically in power I got
it I was tweeting about because during
the health care debate this most recent
healthcare debate just the rhetoric on
the left was unreal it's like the
Republicans are going to kill thousands
of people 20 million people where's
Strip 22 million people from their
health care is just like detached from
any fair reading of reality but it was
you know we have to beat this no matter
what we'll say anything so I was
objecting to this you know they blame
our rhetoric for stuff that has nothing
to do with
rhetoric and then a week after Steve
Scalise gets shot by a Bernie Sanders
supporter Sanders is out there saying
the Republican health care bill would be
like nine 911s every year and I'm like
well like what are the what are the
standards here mm-hmm so I was objecting
to something that Hillary Clinton had
said saying that the Republicans would
be you might as well rename them the
death party or something like that and I
was like wow and some lefty bloggers
found a piece a short blog post that I
wrote in college like 11 years ago
praising a book by Ramesh Ponnuru which
was called the party of death and it was
about abortion and he was just like bang
yeah gotcha and I'm like it's it's sort
of tough to make a life comes at you
fast meme when it's like 11 years apart
yeah and I remember even at the time
asking or mesh like do you think this
title might turn some people off anyway
I get it I mean that's that's Twitter
Twitter culture and we're not going to
be perfect like that's why we say it in
a discussion we are not the exemplars of
perfect like like pristine public
discourse and in return we're just
trying to be better about it and we're
hoping to encourage others to join us
well it's funny because I always find
that I'm basically within these four
walls in this room I'm pretty much at my
best in terms of my intellect how I
treat people all those things it's
already real Twitter
you're not pretty good at my private
life too but Twitter often brings out
the worst in me suddenly I'm fighting
with someone that I don't really care
about you know you see these outrages
all day long I try I've been doing it
less and less but just the other day I
saw somebody had tweeted something about
basically all the white interns now at
the White House and you retweeted it and
you you grabbed I guess from their own
company's website how many white there
were basically zero percent black inter
was a black intern for his leadership
team so he had said look at all these
white male interns that Trump has and I
just went to his bio clicked on his own
website of the company that he founded
and it's like meet the team yeah and the
team was mostly white dudes and no black
people so I just mirrored his tweet but
with his company
and that that kind of went a little bit
viral which I don't think that that's
over the top or like sometimes you've
got to fight back on some of this stuff
because they're fake moralizing that's
the point I don't that's and that's the
thing I didn't think that this guy's
company is morally worse or bad at their
work because it's disproportionately
fill-in-the-blank identity politics
I just think free I think there's
something really weird in someone's head
he was a former Obama official by the
way yeah there's something weird in
someone's head when they see a
photograph of a hundred and twenty
college kids and the first thing they do
is like slop these people into like
gender and race immediately to make some
political point like if that's the game
you're gonna play here's how that might
apply to you and I was by no means
embracing identity politics I was
ridiculing it and I think ridicule is
sometimes one of the better tactics we
have does that show you though how well
their tactics have worked for so long
because now the thinking has gotten so
sloppy so for example I saw a recent
tweet by Chris Hayes from MSNBC talking
about all this scaramouche east up which
again was it's happening right now as we
tape this but it'll be a couple weeks
ago by the time we air this but saying
something like a Lucci might be
president these airs he could be
President he could be put to Siberia
like we have no freaking clue what's
gonna happen but where II might have
connections in Russia he might have
connections in Italy you never know ah
well see I think that's the automatic
that but the point is I saw Chris Hayes
tweeted something's the effect of if
these guys if these were black people
doing this in the White House everybody
would be up in arms
I'm loosely quoting him but I thought
the idea that you took something that
there's no racial not up in arms about
it I mean how much open arms can people
be here so I so I maybe I'm not I may
not have been up in arms as the frame
but point but point being that you took
something that there's no racial
connotation to this discussion in order
to be no one's claiming a scar mu cheese
are racist or there's just nothing
racial about this and now you're giving
it the racial and just to give the meat
to the people that you're talking about
yep right here and I'm dangerous I know
Chris and I like Chris and sometimes we
come at each other with some brush back
pitches on Twitter and that's fine
because I just the gratuitous
endless parade of identity politics it's
just completely exhausting and again
it's it's a substitute it's a shortcut
to sort of bypass any real debate and
that's actually the way that we describe
end of discussion it's how primarily the
left is trying to win cultural debates
and political debates by preventing the
debates from happening they want to win
by default
just because we're bad we're blankest
and therefore our ideas don't need a
fair hearing because obviously all
rights are like this self-fulfilling
tautology they're bad because they're
bad because they're bad and end of
discussion
and we're like no that's that's not how
this should go who's your kind of
Republican if you were looking at all of
them oh boy
tell me on a Republican I am open-minded
truly any of them give me give me
somebody that you think is doing this
thing right from from the Republican
perspective again you said you're more
of a conservative than the public all
right so just from a conservative
perspective who do you think is
basically doing it right I really like
Ben Sasse mm-hmm
the Nebraska senator I think he's
principled I think he's really smart I
think he's got a great sense of what
civic duty means and shouldn't mean
there's a sense of humor he's funny
he does he does this stuff where he goes
to his home state and he works a full
day on a variety of jobs randomly no
press no cameras he'll go and work at a
mechanics shop for a nine hour day and
just like show me what you do talk to me
about your life he drives uber which is
that right he drives uber it's
incredible I just I think he's really
good and I'm sure you can find something
where I disagree with him or where I
think he's done something wrong but I
think he's great and I I really get the
sense in meeting with him and talking
with him that he means it when he says
the the goal of my life is not to be a
u.s. senator right that this is not the
end-all be-all of life and he's got a
really interesting book out as long as
we're plugging books I like in terms of
the Trump administration I really like
nikki Haley at the
UN I think she did a really nice job in
South Carolina as governor she navigated
some difficult things quite well she has
been willing to step out and say things
that are not necessarily the exact party
line all the time with some moral
clarity about some important things and
certainly not the UN party yeah yeah
definitely not I mean but not even the
Trump party what I'm saying so those are
two I don't want to exclude anyone
there's plenty of people in the party
that I really respect and like even if
they have their quirks and there's no
such thing as a perfect political figure
and when you start to think that there
is you're gonna get super disappointed
yeah well that's also why I focus on
left because I came from the left but
also that they seem to have this concept
that if they could only get their people
in everything would be perfect so it's
never about the principles it's only
Barney would get in or Elizabeth Warren
again everything will become perfect and
that's such a that that hero worship and
again there's plenty of people that
worship Trump so I'm not saying that
doesn't it yes but that sort of hero
worship I think is the most dangerous
thing I would rather take the power away
from all of these people yeah I think
we'd be in better shape no personality
cults are weird and creepy especially in
politics and I think it sort of robs
people of reason where and just like the
double standards that drives me it
drives me crazy
where you have people and this is
tribalism right people willing to defend
almost anything if it's their guy when
they would be going apoplectic if it was
the other side doing it and there's no
real argument for it other than well
that's them and they're bad and we're us
and we're not yeah we're good
we're for America okay and it's sort of
like you know I mean get with the
program or get lost
CUC yeah it's just like all right I mean
great you you've persuaded me right
right like what and anyway but I don't
think most Americans are caught up in
the the hardcore like you know hero
worship thing I do think it's very odd
how the left in particular feels like
they can somehow perfect society through
political action
and the horrible it's always messed up
if we only had more of it right it would
fix everything socialism's never really
been tried properly right Venezuela no
but there's reasons it yeah they've
screwed that up but believe me the
principles work we'll get back to us on
how yeah yeah all right well let me ask
you a little more difficult question
than Republicans that you respect are
there any Democrats that you think
haven't gone completely insane no
they're all bad for America no I mean
look there there are some Democrats that
I certainly respect more than others
sometimes I'll play this game with so my
liberal friends like who you know who's
your favorite and they're a cop-out
answers like you know my favorite
Democratic senator was Zell Miller yeah
you know who just gave a wild
stem-winder of a speech at the
Republican yeah yeah that was the most
confusing thing it was the line like you
never remember lines from convention
speeches but I remember him ripping into
John Kerry and saying what does he think
we can defend America with spitballs and
everyone went crazy um she bothers me
sometimes but I have to say that I
respect Dianne Feinstein I think that
she's not always predictable she's not
always a hack I think she takes national
security pretty seriously
I just pickin her cuz she's on her way
out well no but I think she has respect
for institutions I have to confess I
like Joe Biden I think that he's just
sort of a fun dude that I like to hang
out with but when you see a guy like
Biden or even when you see the modern
what what are thought of as more of the
moderates even though they're probably
all too big government for you but when
you think of like a Chuck Schumer or a
Biden or sort of that older group do you
think it's over for that wing like do
you think that the I'm not sure Bernie
Murr counts as that rights right so
humor somewhere in the middle and I look
I have no love loss for Chuck Schumer
but like he also voted against her and
they didn't really ever vote on it but
he came out against the Iran deal yeah I
thought was well that's a there's a
little more of a centrist he didn't
write either party line there I see the
left now dragging the Democrats much
further to the left do you see that any
chance for
where you think those moderates are
whether you include Schumer in that or
Joe Biden even though he's very worried
that we are heading in a European model
direction where we have an ever-growing
state we have socialists to the left and
sort of more nationalists to the right
and there's not much of a real home or
constituency for limited government
constitutional conservatism that is
something that I'm concerned about I
think for a number of reasons I don't
feel welcome I we alluded to this
earlier I don't feel welcome in the
Democratic Party and even when I am at
peak exasperation with the Republicans
the Democrats show up and do something
I'm like well nope
yeah but the Republicans have been
trying awfully hard to alienate me and I
think part of it is just like all right
try to stay intellectually grounded take
each issue and circumstance as it comes
and evaluate it as best as I can on the
merits and that's how I try to go about
my job writing at townhall
giving analysis on Fox News and that's
the best I can do and it's gonna make
some people unhappy and that's fine and
hopefully some other people are gonna
find it refreshing and I just sort of
let the chips fall yeah
so when you say Constitution limited
government all of that low tax stuff all
that kind of stuff what about a Rand
Paul to just it's the foreign policy
stuff that gets here yeah yeah I think
he's probably a little bit like I would
take him over his dad any day of the
week I I don't think and part of me is
also like there's a pragmatism element
here as well like I think it there are
certain people who are outside of the
Overton Window of electability
nationally now maybe I'm not the best
judge of that because based on all of
his polling numbers I thought that the
man who was elected president couldn't
be elected he had the wonderful benefit
of running against a truly historically
atrocious candidate who's writing a book
about why she lost I'm sure that's gonna
be a wonderful compelling what's it
called what happened what happened what
happened I mean what a terrible name for
it can be he'll one page book maybe one
sentence book I'm Tara
yeah the end you know but yeah Rand Paul
I don't know this last election has made
me think long and hard about how many
people actually view the world and view
the political system the way I do I used
to think that people like me were the
clear majority within the Republican
Party and I am less convinced of that
than ever and so Rand Paul is I think in
theory I'm with him on a lot of yeah
I don't know if that is gonna sell to
the American people I mean look at I
mean we we elected a Republican
president who drew a line in the sand
saying I will not touch the entitlement
programs which are which have to be it's
just basic math and George will have
this column if the Republicans are no
longer going to be the party of math
what is the point of them mm-hmm and
that's something that I'm worried about
so it's interesting in an odd way I'm
frustrated with the left because I see
them going too far left big government
and you're frustrated with the right
because you see them trending in that
direction too yeah yeah so that's a
really interesting spot to be in and I
do think there was all this like
thumb-sucking analysis for years about
how the Republicans were this moving
radically to the right and they were
unrecognizable and there was very little
parallel commentary about what was
happening on the Left I don't I'm not
exactly sure what the Republican Party
is and what exactly it stands for aside
from not the left there's something
useful in being not the left
I think fighting the left is a useful
worthwhile endeavor but aside from sort
of the the anti left general impulse or
sentiment I'm not exactly sure what the
coherent philosophy of the party is
mmm-hmm
which is a weird feeling to have but
that's that's where we are I think for
me so one of the things that I've talked
about with almost everyone in the last
couple months at least anyone that's
political on the show has been that
almost everyone has been satisfied with
the destruction that's happening with
mainstream media right now
you're sort of on both sides of it
because you're you're a mainstream guy
as we said you do stuff on Fox but you
do online stuff as well like you know
the fact that you have a Twitter
presence that's active like you get
internet culture I think are you as
satisfied as I am the mainstream media
is crumbling because I'm pretty thrilled
I think there's been such a destructive
aspect to it and to your point earlier
of they were we're all leftists and
watching that crumble so hopefully
something more sane will come out of it
I may be wrong yeah that may give all
the power to the Alex Joneses of the
world yeah I mean I've I've always
believed in a marketplace of ideas and
not this top-down media environment
where you know for many years for
decades it was basically two newspapers
and three networks decided what the news
was and that was it and slowly but
surely people have been chipping away at
that would talk radio in Fox News and of
course now the internet which I think
it's if this is a positive development
for sure
and I think that the biased media that
it's so funny that they are always
worried about the credibility of other
people and they seem less aware that
their own credibility is like a thing
then they have lost in the eyes of many
people like when a lot of polling shows
the media less trusted than Trump like
that should be a wake-up call but for
them it's sort of like they're on this
high horse and it's in like it's not
penetrating yeah so I take a good deal
of satisfaction in sort of seeing some
of that come down because it's it's
earned
they've deserved it I don't think it's
an unmitigated positive either though
because for two reasons first I do
believe in objective truth I do believe
that there is something that is correct
and something that is incorrect and I
think it is useful to have people who
are credible who can call those shots
and I'm not saying that the media has
epitomized this because they haven't
yeah but we do need those voices which
is why I appreciate people like Jake
Tapper or Bret Baier and that there's a
number of them
we need to value that still and not
throw the baby out with the bathwater
completely and then the other side of
this concern that I have is we in this
and in this current media environment we
can just construct delightful
comfortable cocoon like echo chambers
for ourselves where we pick and choose
like on Spotify the only stuff we want
to listen to and ingest and then just
dismiss everything else as fake or
biased or right-wing propaganda or fake
news or whatever you know the term is
gonna be and that does not contribute to
a healthy society when you have large
sections of the country off in their
separate ideological silos where
counter-arguments don't really penetrate
and there's not a devotion to truth and
intellectual honesty that's not I don't
think that's a positive so do you think
we could have a legit third party then
for the for the refugees of the left
that I like that I think I'm trying to
offer what what classical liberalism or
real liberalism is for guys like you
that are gone the parties actually not
doing the conservative things that I
want them to do you just think it the
machine is too big the machine and then
also just like so okay and here's here's
why I'm not optimistic on that front and
again I could be proven wrong I don't
think that I have you know I'm have the
last word on any of this stuff but what
you're learning not everything you say
here will prove out to be absolutely I'd
give myself like a like a 92% accuracy
rating give or take I will do this again
in a year for just like play back the
tape I said here with a bag over my head
but I think the the data point I would
point to is the 2016 election right on
election day according to all the exit
polling Donald Trump had a 60 percent
disapproval rating any one Hillary
Clinton had a 55 56 percent disapproval
rating these are toxic people who most
people did not like did not trust
couldn't relate to it was our two major
parties put
the very worst really that they possibly
could and they still got you know
combined for what 95 96 percent of the
national vote I mean the libertarians
put out a ticket of two former
multi-term governors who sort of crash
and burn and were terrible Jill Stein
sort of a moon bat you know Evan
McMullen who has turned out to be super
annoying like this was the moment this
was the mode be like these parties are
failing they suck so hard
someone and and it was just nothing so
who knows someone might have mortality I
wasted my vote on Garry Johnson I don't
think it's a wasted vote so I voted for
a third party as well I well I thought
well I assume you mean Garry Johnson 26
what other third party could have you
voted for in 2016 hold that thought I
honestly felt like every person running
for president was actively trying to
lose my vote at all times
like I'd be like I'd watch Hillary oh my
god she's awful yeah maybe that's second
look at Trump then I turned him on I'm
like oh God
like all right Gary give it to me
and it's like nope nope nope nope and so
it's like the person that I heard from
most recently was the one I was most
upset with all the time yeah so it
that's but again I don't think it's a
wasted vote like I don't think that
anyone just deserves my vote by the like
I don't think the Democrats deserve my
vote cuz I'm gay I don't think the
Republicans always deserve my vote just
because I'm more with them than not like
it does take a lot for me not to vote
for a Republican but by god it's been
happening yeah but so who did you vote
for I ended up voting for McMullen
really yeah
just he was on the ballot in Virginia I
actually sat in the booth or stood there
in the voters booth there were four
names on the ballot it was Hillary Trump
Johnson and McMullen I actually
interviewed Gary Johnson for Town Hall
in a sit-down like this oh you're right
I saw it that was what I finally snapped
against him because you did a great job
of that in except the purpose of the
interview was to be like dude you're
this Liberty
arian and you keep trying to sell Bernie
supporters like sell me yeah I should be
your target audience so they agreed they
came we sat down and I wanted to ask him
about limited government and all this
stuff and he jumped down my throat about
using the term illegal immigrants and
got super triggered by it and told me
you can't use that term and start
shouting and I was like bro like what
are you doing here I'm so glad you
mentioned that because I forgot that you
were the one that did that and I talked
about it because I had about a month
before the first debate I publicly did
this thing about why I'm gonna support
Kerry Johnson I just want new ideas out
there I want limited government and no
taxes to be heard at least an individual
rights ababa and I knew he wasn't gonna
it wasn't gonna work but whatever I said
I'm gonna at least try if I can do
anything with my voice let me try at
least but then there was the Aleppo
thing and he couldn't name the leader he
liked but then your interview to me was
the one where it like completely snapped
and again he's a decent man I you know
but because he kept saying the thing
about because you kept saying illegal
immigrant and he said it's an incendiary
term but you kept asking him or are they
not illegal are they not illegal and
then at the end I mean he basically was
like yes you're right and I was like
that was the worst I don't want to pile
on the guy what's the point anyway look
I think we're we he did a nice job there
but I stood there on Election Day
looking at these four names and I really
had this moment where I contemplated
checking the box for all of them at some
like running through the list and the
one that I felt least agita or
indigestion over at the time was Evan
McMullen although he seems to be working
over time since the election to make me
regret my vote for him with just sort of
the nonstop Russia hysteria I believe
that the Russia investigation is
important I am NOT you know
automatically inclined to believe that
Trump is or his people are completely
innocent or whatever I think the way
they've handled has been terrible but
the hysteria and the and the feeding of
that fire is just it's too much and and
he's been at the forefront of that and
it's like oh man yeah there were no good
options on the ballot for me and I know
that's not true for a lot of people
there's probably people watching
screaming you know so
like of course Trump was the best option
are you stupid I see the argument for
that I could I could sit here and make
the cogent make America great again
argument totally and there are large
elements of truth to it
just for me I found and that we don't
have to relitigate this election it's so
depressing but I thought that he was
fundamentally unfit to be President and
I thought she was epically unfit and
ideologically unacceptable well I like
talking to somebody that's trying to you
know stay true to their morals and their
philosophy in the midst of a political
thing that's tough all right well I
think we should do this again sometime
yeah you know we were gonna go out
tonight but and I think we would have
had the most boring game night people
think when gay people go out it's gonna
be some incredible but I don't sense
that the two of us could we would have
fun but nice conversation but it
wouldn't have been like whatever they
think gay people are doing I don't think
we could have got there I mean I brought
I'm having dinner with friends who have
kids now and then I said maybe I'll meet
after and you were like I got to get to
bed early I mean this is pathetic
hang on I this is this is you're
revealing all the secrets here I how do
you know that I don't have glitter and
ecstasy just waiting well because the
way you said glitter and yeah there's
just no chance it's been a long long day
and I'm very much looking forward to
sleep too all right I can lend you some
glitter but I can't go out unfortunately
it was a pleasure it was a pleasure
talking to you and for more on guy
follow him on that Twitter machine it's
at guy P that's it
[Music]
you
[Music]